determine whether the system has no
solutions or infinite solutions so
they're telling us right from the get-go
that we're not gonna have one nice clean
solution here so let's just try to solve
this system and so to solve the system
we want to eliminate one variable first
so let's say let's say we want to focus
on eliminating let's eliminate the x's
so if we want to eliminate the X's if I
multiply this first equation over here
by negative four then this will become a
negative 8x which should be able to
cancel out with this 8x over here so let
me multiply it by negative four so times
negative four so 2 times negative four
is negative 8x negative 4y times
negative 4 is plus 16y
negative four times Z is negative 4z and
then that is going to be equal to
negative four times 3 is negative 12 and
then let me just rewrite the second
equation right over here we have 8x
minus 2y plus 4z is equal to 7 and now
we can add these two equations and
hopefully eliminate the X terms negative
8x plus 8x they eliminate 16 Y minus 2y
is 14 Y and then negative 4z plus 4z
those also eliminate we were able to
eliminate an X and a Z and one fell
swoop and so we get 14 Y is equal to we
have negative 12 plus we have negative
12 plus 7 is negative 5 we have negative
5 just like that and actually we could
solve this this is one equation in one
unknown but we haven't used the third
constraint yet we haven't used this
constraint over here so we have we could
actually solve it divide both sides by
14 divide both sides by 14 and we get Y
is equal to negative negative 5 negative
5 over 14 so that's interesting but it
doesn't necessarily tell us much about
the solution in just yet you want to be
very careful about kind of back
substituting in all of that because we
haven't used all of the constraints yet
we still haven't used this third
constraint so our goal was to
X's from the get-go so let's still try
to eliminate X's using these second two
constraints and see if we get anything
interesting and the reason why I'm being
especially wary is because they're
telling us that this thing either has no
solutions or an infinite number of
solutions so let's use these second two
constraints and we can eliminate the X
here if we keep the first equation the
same and we multiply the second equation
by two because this will become a
negative 8x which will eliminate so our
first equation is just 8x minus 2y plus
4z is equal to seven just rewrote it and
then the second equation over here I'm
going to multiply it by two multiplied
by two negative 4x times two is negative
8x y times two is plus 2y positive 2y
negative 2z times 2 is negative 4z and
then negative 14 times two is negative
negative 28 and something very
interesting is about to happen when you
use these two constraints when you use
these two constraints when you try to
find the intersection essentially
between these two planes you get
something very bizarre 8x minus 8x is 0
to Y negative 2y plus 2y is another 0
for Z minus 4z another zero and seven
minus twenty eight is negative 21 so
using these two constraints you get this
kind of nonsensical statement or not
inconsistent statement that 0 is equal
to negative 21
this obviously can never happen so this
is we end up with no no solution if we
got something like 0 is equal to 0 or 21
is equal to 21 or negative 21 is equal
to 21 then it would mean that we have
the same exact planes which would mean
we have an infinite number of solutions
in this circumstance right here we have
the same coefficients but when you add
them up in this weighted way you get a
different result so these are actually
going to be parallel planes so if you
were to graph this plane in this plane
one would look like that and then the
other would look like this
and so the only way that they could
intersect is if 0 is equal to negative
21 and we know that's impossible they
never ever intersect these two planes so
regardless of this first constraint and
all of the stuff we did here these two
planes will never
intersect these two right over here and
so we have no solutions